منذ السابع من اكتوبر وقرار اسرائيل
السياسي والعسكري رهن بمجلس الحرب وحكومه
الطوارئ التي تضم 38 وزيرا من اللكود
واحزاب دينيه متطرفه واخرين من حزب
المعسكر الرسمي الذي يقوده بيني جانس خارج
هذه الجدران ترك هؤلاء خلافهم السياسي
مصدرين للجبهه الداخليه صوره الوحده
والتمترس معا في خندق واحد لتحقيق اهداف
الحرب تدمير حركه حماس سحق حماس وقتل
قادتها او اعتقالهم بحيث لا تقوى الحركه
على النهوض من تحت انقاض غزه اعاده كافه
الاسرى والمحتجزين اجنده مثقله بلاءات لا
لوقف الحرب لا للتفاوض لا لادخال اي
مساعدات لغزه مواقف جمعت معارضي نتنياهو
وحلفائه السياسيون منهم
والعسكريون الحرب مستمره وستستمر حتى
النهايه حتى نحقق جميع اهدافنا وهي اعاده
المختطفين والقضاء على حماس وضمان ان غزه
لن تشكل اي تهديد لاسرائيل بعد
الان غريم نتنياهو السياسي وشريكه في
حكومه الحرب بين جانس تناسى الرجلان
خلافاتهما لتتحدث حكومه الطوارئ بلسان
واحد ولون واحد سحق غزه لاعاده الاسرى و
[موسيقى]
حس وغير من القاده الاسرائيليين مسؤولون
عن اعاده المحتجزين وازاله تهديد حركه
حماس نهائيا نتكبد خسائر كبيره في غزه حيث
يخوض الجيش حربا معقده ومركبه لكننا
سنواصل
القتال طالت الحرب ولم تتحقق اهدافها في
الشهر الرابع من القتال ثمه تبدل في
المواقف داخل معاقل صنع القرار في تل ابيب
يكشف عن تصدع حتى داخل معسكر نتنياهو نفسه
لتغطي ضبابيه كبيره صوره الجبهه الموحده
لاسرائيل فلم تعد تصل بالوضوح الذي كان
قبل 100 يوم تعل اصوات وزنه داخل الحكومه
ومجلس الحرب تدعو لوقف القتال واستعاده
الاسرى دعوه يتبناها رئيس الاركان السابق
جادي ايزنكوت وهو الذي فقد ابنه خلال
القتال في غزه علينا التوقف عن الكذب على
انفسنا وانتحل بالشجاعه ونتوجه الى صفقه
كبيره تعيد المختطفين الى وطنهم كذلك يدعو
جانس بان تفكر اسرائيل خارج الصندوق وتعطي
الاولويه لعوده المختطفين حتى مقابل وقف
الحرب داعيا اسماء لم يذكرها للتوقف عن
الاعيب
السياسه تعلو هذه الدعوات باصوات اخرى من
داخل الحكومه بل من معسكر نتنياهو نفسه
كالوزير افي دختر الذي ينتقد عمليات
التهجير الكبيره من
غزه في المقابل يبقى نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع
يواف جالانت ومعهما وزراء اليمين المتطرف
في الحكومه على نهج الضغط العسكري لتحرير
الرهائن
[موسيقى]
الطريقه الوحيده التي ستعيد المختطفين هي
الضغط العسكري كلما كانت العمليات
العسكريه اشد واقوى ووصلت الى اماكن اشد
ايما بالنسبه اليهم تمكنا من تحقيق
نتائج لكن جالانت يشذ عن هذا الاجماع
برؤيته لليوم التالي للحرب بضروره ان يكون
للسلطه الف دور في حكم غزه خلافا لما
ينادي به نتنياهو وما يدعو له سموتريتش
وبنك فير ومعهما كثير من وزراء اليمين
المتطرف مواقف ورؤى متباينه للحرب وما
بعدها تكشف كم يتعمق الشقاق داخل حكومه
رات النور كي تدير الحرب وزراء اقصى
اليمين يخيرون نتنياهو بينهم وبين معسكر
لبيد جانس لا يرضيهم نهج اداره الحرب
ويسوقهم سحب قوات من
غزه نتنياهو الاختيار بيننا وبين طريق
جانس ولابد نريد الحسم في الشمال والجنوب
وتحقيق الانتصار بالقضاء على
اعدائنا خلافات نتنياهو وجانت جبهه حرب
سابعه يصفها الاعلام الاسرائيلي يكشف موقع
ولا ان وزير الدفاع حاول اقتحام مكتب
نتنياهو كادت الاوضاع تتدهور نحو شجار
بالايدي وهدد جالانت باحضار لواء جولاني
للسيطره على الوضع داخل مجلس الحرب اما في
شوارع تل فتزداد جذوه المظاهرات المعارضه
لسياسات نتنياهو وادارته للحرب يطالب
هؤلاء باستقاله نتنياهو واعاده المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين من قطاع غزه كان لافتا
مشاركه عضو مجلس الحرب بن جانس في اكبر
المظاهرات حشدا وهل ثمت ما هو ادل من ذلك
على مدى الخلافات التي تعصف بمجلس
الحرب